hello Evan and welcome to the genetics
and genomics virtual event my name is
mark keel and I am the chief science
officer and co-founder of genomic on and
I'll be presenting today on AI driven
literature curation for determining
genomic variant pathogenicity please
feel free to submit us through the chat
during my presentation and I'll follow
up with you during the live event by
email so today I want to talk about the
use of our flagship product mastermind
which is a genomic search engine for
ACMG variant interpretation but before I
begin I'd like to talk a bit about why
we're here how we figure into the
challenge of precision medicine using
genomics go through a little bit of a
background and explicitly layout the
problem statement then I'll talk about
the mastermind software that I alluded
to and go through a couple of case
examples that are representative of
those that our users have experienced
and why they're so happy with the
results they're seeing in mastermind and
then take all of that into account and
talk about what genomics future outlook
is for help
rotate the full realization of precision
medicine in the genomic era and then
I'll conclude and allow people to sign
up to the mastermind software which is
available for wide use so why are we
here well NGS or next-generation
deepening as you're undoubtedly aware
has dramatically changed the face of
molecular medicine and increasingly the
utility of this modality is recognized
in clinical practice not just for cancer
but also for constitutional disease so
the utility in different patient
populations is expanding and it's also
the case that for an increasing number
of different types of patients the
utility of NGS is increasingly being
recognized so there's this very strong
incentive
for molecular diagnostic and pathology
labs to implement next-generation
sequencing into their clinical care and
aggro number of labs are doing so if
they're not already implementing NGS
either whole exome or whole genome or
very large comprehensive gene panels
they're making moves in that direction
and this is very exciting from my
perspective because I entered graduate
school when the human genome project was
being completed and I matriculated into
molecular pathology training through my
clinical pathology residency right as
the next-generation DNA sequencing
revolution was underway and so I feel
like we're more than ever on the verge
of fully harnessing the power of genomic
medicine and though the details are
complex the goals of realizing
personalized medicine in the genomic era
are really quite simple and simply put
they are to explain a patient's genetic
disease or if you magnify that on
implicate groups genetic disease and
even further and increasingly to use
that knowledge to predict the
development of disease even before
symptoms appear
the real challenge there is to do this
quickly and inexpensively so in previous
circumstances I've said that the human
genome project that I alluded to earlier
made it seem possible that we could
realize this vision of precision
medicine through genomics and the
next-generation DNA sequencing
revolution made it seem like it was
plausible that that could happen where
we could sequence sequence of pins
genome in routine clinical practice and
what we're faced with now is this
challenge of doing that quickly and
inexpensively and as I'll allude to in
subsequent slides that is properly
referred to as the bioinformatics
bottleneck and the challenge there is
making it practical making cost
effective and making it possible to get
this information
interpret this data quickly enough so
that it's beneficial to patients who
have been recently diagnosed clinically
or who otherwise don't yet know that
they have genetic disease so how can we
make this happen this is a useful slide
that schematize --is the opportunities
that are afforded by the NGS revolution
and some prevailing parameters in
clinical medicine but also highlight
some opposing forces so at the top there
the new opportunities include rheumatic
reduction in the cost to produce
sequence data this is superseded Moore's
law for shrinking the size and reducing
the cost and increasing the data content
on silicon chips we have not seen as a
species such a dramatic improvement in
in technological advance as we have in
the reduction in the cost and the time
it takes to produce DNA sequencing data
and so that feeds forward through this
pipeline and greatly facilitates the
ability for genetics labs and pathology
labs to automate their laboratory
workflow and beyond the ability to
streamline and automate laboratory
workflow with NGS sequencing technology
as I've alluded to there's an increasing
awareness of the utility of this genetic
data for multiple patients and multiple
different patient types and even
multiple circumstances as we're seeing
with unveiled prenatal testing or
otherwise liquid biopsy for detecting
cancers at a molecular level before
symptoms are manifest and I'd like to
call this the virtuous circle of using
next-generation DNA sequencing to inform
that research and almost immediately
having that research informed clinical
practice and then coming back around
again where increasingly larger and
larger clinical studies can be performed
using NGS to further enhance the
research and so that we've seen play out
certainly since my graduate student days
but we've seen it play out
and it seems to
exponentiating in value but there are
challenges and those challenges include
the the payer system and the minimal
reimbursement for diagnosis that takes
place even where costs for producing
this data are decreasing it's such a new
technology and the healthcare
infrastructure has not yet risen to the
challenge of ensuring that this
sequencing modality is made available to
all patient types and even further
there's next to no reimbursement for
prevention where particularly in the
United States the the healthcare model
is predicated on treating symptoms after
disease has developed and very minimal
effort is expended on behalf of
preventive techniques and part of the
reason for that is that there's a lack
of an incentive to reimburse for those
types of interventions or rather a lack
of awareness of the benefit of
intervening early before disease
presents itself but the last piece there
perhaps the most important and the one
that I want to touch on most during this
talk here is the high interpretation
cost so if you go up to the upper left
where I began there's this dramatic
decrease in the cost to produce the data
but there has been this stasis in terms
of how much time and therefore cost it
is required to interpret that data so
we're the upper left the NGS sequencing
improvements have increased the amount
of data that we can produce
exponentially in most cases that leads
to annotation of interpretation cost and
that is the real sticking point for
fully realizing genomic medicine a
little bit of data to put on a finer
point on on my assertion there part of
the challenge with high interpretation
cost is that with the increased use of
next-generation sequencing and more and
more patients being sequenced in this
way we're finding more and more things
more and more portions of the genome
either additional axons or more genes
bigger panels up to and including whole
exomes and old genomes are being
sequenced on a root and so naturally
we're discovering more things than we
learned or knew about before and that is
challenging the efficiency of the genome
or exome or panel interpretation process
so this is from a recent study in
genetics and medicine that demonstrated
that 40% all pathogenic variants after
interpretation has been performed for
these large studies exomes or large
panels are novel and that means they've
never been seen before and it requires
that variant scientists pathologists or
geneticists need to investigate that
data in the flip side of that from the
same study is an indication that 60% of
the variants that are seen as a result
of those molecular assays are seen once
and only once and so putting these
together you can see how even with an
increased publication rate and
representation of the variants that
we're now learning about from clinical
practice or from research efforts
increasingly in clinical practice we're
seeing this 40% to 60% of variants that
are novel and demand extra care and
attention and can't simply have been
free to be extracted from existing
database so I've alluded to this before
but I'll lay it bare here this is a
colloquialism in the genomics field
there's the thousand-dollar genome it's
actually decreased below that price
point afforded by fact NGS has no longer
made sequencing the rate limiting step
indeed it's become a commodity but
there's nevertheless this million-dollar
interpretation and that million-dollar
interpretation or the bioinformatics
bottleneck means that we have to
interpret the data still again to put a
finer point on why that challenge
there's just too much information
there's so many variants as I
and there's a large amount of data
associated with each of those variants
that are necessary to properly
understand what those variants mean in
clinical practice another challenge is
that this data is very unstructured
there are databases that I'll say that
I'll talk to in a moment where there's
high degrees of structure around those
data sets because they were produced
with a view toward using them in
high-throughput but by and large the
critical pieces of information coming
from empirical studies in us molecule
clinical studies are highly unstructured
and they come from the empirical medical
literature that has been produced over
many decades of genetic investigation so
too much information and highly
unstructured information are two huge
challenges in scaling variant
interpretation some other challenges are
that while there are steps forward in
routine izing the process of
interpreting these variants and the data
that goes along with the variants the
guidelines are complicated I think
almost by necessity but the fact that
they're complicated and the fact that
the intuition is vast and unstructured
has really challenged our ability to
streamline their implementation
particularly in automated workflows and
we'll speak to that in a slide or two
here and then finally I'll emphasize a
growing challenge in the genomics field
for clinical medicine and that is the
mandate to reinterpret data so you'll
you'll get a sense for a consistent
thread through this talk that the
clinical information available in the
scientific literature and from the
research that's being done in research
labs does not stop it particularly does
not stop as a result of that yet
revolution and so there's there's this
continual need if you come up empty and
find no information about your variant
there is a continual need to return to
that literature to return to those data
stores of information and see if
anything new has come up that will
change the patient's
gnosis and inform their clinical care in
a way that was not possible six months
ago or three months ago or even a week
ago because no information was available
at that time so with respect to the
interpretation guidelines it's it's the
substance of the talk that I want to lay
out here it is the ACMG variant
interpretation guidelines from this
reference here that I'm showcasing ACMG
for those that aren't aware is American
College of medical genetics and genomics
and they've allied with the Association
for molecular pathology to produce this
framework for interpretation of their
means various data stores that I've
mentioned to both increase the accuracy
of the variant interpretations for
variants that are coming out of these
large-scale next-generation sequencing
platforms large panels exomes or genomes
but also to increase the reproducibility
of the interpretations so if you are to
different variant interpretation groups
or even within the same group to
different variant scientists if you have
available to you all of the same
information all of the same data for a
molecular lab there's every hope and
expectation that those two
interpretations would be identical and
that's effectively what the goal of the
ACMG amp scoring criteria is is to
enhance the reproducibility and accuracy
of these variant interpretations and
their site there's very positive signs
that these guidelines are being widely
adopted they've been adopted outside of
the US and the UK they've been published
in Chinese to meet the demands in that
expanding Asian market and they're used
by 95% of labs worldwide which is a very
positive sign although there are some
challenges typically idiosyncratic
challenges in different circumstances
that make this attempt to simplify and
reduce to practice the variant
interpretation guidelines but as a
community those are being worked out
and so let's let's examine the ACMG
criteria in a little bit more detail it
this will not be an existed discussion
of the ACMG criteria but rather at a
high level there's what I like to say
evidence triad for interpreting the
meaningfulness and clinical significance
of variants that come out of exome
genome or large panel molecular assays
two of those at the base of the pyramid
are statistics on population frequency
in healthy normal cohorts so that's
population data that comes from
resources like no matter exact or ESP
6500 which many of you will be familiar
with that's one arm of the triangle
another arm is computational data or in
silico models that predict pathogenicity
of a given variant based on
3-dimensional confirmation of the
protein awareness of domain structure
and or understanding of evolutionary
conservation and together those two
facets of the evidence triad are
typically not sufficient for a variant
to be interpreted and so properly those
variants that are otherwise not
interpretable are called variants of
uncertain significance or v us and the
way that we better understand those v us
and decide which ones of those variants
of uncertain significance are pathogenic
requires literature curation requires
evidence either at a functional level
where authors of scientific studies have
performed feel in vitro studies of the
consequence of that patient's variant
and have determined that there's some
change in the function of the protein
that would be a strong indication of
pathogenicity for the variant scientist
who's tasked with understanding this
patient's data similarly different than
the healthy normal popular
in statistics that comes from that first
arm of the Triad that I talked about
case studies either individual pro bands
within a single pedigree or otherwise
multiple pedigrees or large cohorts of
patients who have had a sequencing
performed and where the research the
clinical researchers have identified
segregation patterns of that variant
tracking with development of disease in
those patients so functional studies and
clinical suggestion data those are the
two major components of evidence that
inform the ACMG classification schema
and increasingly those require
literature curation so that's where I
want to spend the rest of the time
talking about the challenge of parsing
the literature identifying the right
references and parsing those references
to pull out the needed information to
make the designation of likely
pathogenic or pathogenic according to
this ACMG framework so I'm a clinical
pathologist so this is the air I breathe
what are we missing and why do we have
much of this information when I really
want to answer this particular question
so that's sensitivity and specificity so
in the first scenario sensitivity the
question that you're asking yourselves
is a variant scientist is am I missing
any publications and the place that most
labs are going to now is their their
standard recourse when when doing
literature investigation which is
typically PubMed or Google or Google
Scholar and so with a simple search in
Google Scholar you may return no
documents no results the question still
remains is that because of some
inaccuracy in my search query or is it
truly because there's no evidence in the
medical literature that matches the
variant that I saw on my patient and
there's myriad ways that you can perform
a search and not return any results when
in fact those results do exist things as
simple
not including synonyms of the gene that
you're searching for or the very
complicated variant nomenclature and the
the multiple different ways that a
variant can be accurately described
either following convention or using
colloquial names and so a negative
result in a non-technical tool like
Google Scholar is is still meeting with
unease for variant scientists who aren't
sure that they've performed the searches
as comprehensively as they otherwise
could the other problem which I'm
illustrating here for a different
variant is there's just too much
information so Google is vast it doesn't
just include scientific literature and
patents as Google Scholar does but it
includes a great deal of additional
information and depending on what you've
searched for you can either have many
thousands of potentially on Birgit
results or otherwise many hundreds or
thousands of results that are false
positives and both of those scenarios
get to the the question of which
publications should I be paying
attention to I don't have time to look
through these thousands or hundreds of
papers I want a more specific result to
be returned to me so sensitivity and
specificity are a huge challenge that
limits the ability to automate this
literature curation challenge for
varying interpretation but then suppose
you do have a maximally sensitive
solution just let's say before I start
talking about mastermind let's say it's
a magic solution and you also have a way
to specifically Devine which of those
references are going to be most
beneficial in your curation you still
have the challenge of extracting that
information from an unstructured
sometimes very dense scientific
publication and in many scenarios you've
you've prioritized your data by
maximizing the specificity of your
search to a couple dozen references
and in typical research studies that
have looked into this matter is fully
investigating of individual patients
vary in just a single variant can take
between 30 minutes and 3 hours depending
on the complexity of the result the
number of references that are returned
and the type of evidence that is being
sought after to accurately score the
variant for ACMG criteria so at present
extracting this genetic information from
these references requires human
intervention and where we think that
will always be true we do feel at
genomic on particularly facilitated by
the tools that we're building in the
form of mastermind that requirement can
wane with advances in automation where
the final arbiter will always be
humanized expert very very well-trained
variant interpret interpreters but we
feel like there's a great deal of
legwork that can still be automated and
that's what I want to highlight here
toward the the last half of the talk so
just to summarize what I've mentioned
here and to put it in the context of the
field in general manual literature
curation doesn't scale it's too
time-consuming
there aren't enough expert variant
scientists trained to meet the patient's
ample demand and the larger mission of
precision medicine in genomics there's
just too few of us who have been
adequately trained to meet this need and
increasingly as I mentioned before the
litigants up in in the past year or so
there have been over half a million new
studies that have genetic or genomic
content and it seems to be growing at a
fast clip so that's the background
that's the problem statement and as I
said for those last part of the talk I'd
like to introduce those aren't failure
the mastermind genomic database it's
properly a search engine
that's a comprehensive index of the
genomic literature that's annotated for
clinical and functional variants so I
like to say imagine if Google Scholar
never slept and had to miss cool and
specialized in genetics and molecular
pathology that's effectively what we've
created and mastermind and we've
presented the results in a way that we
know comports with what variant
scientists are looking for from their
results so in essence we've made it
comes to minimize the manual work that's
required to first find the right
material to organize and annotate that
material and then very quickly make
decisions based on the evidence that's
presented to you so this slide is a
reflection of the data content in the
mastermind genomic database we are
saying fully all of the titles and
abstracts that comprise the medical
literature and even more fully we
understand all of the content in six and
a half million full-text genomic
articles as they are indexed very
thoroughly for any one of many thousands
of different this is the whole spectrum
of human disease and we will be soon
adding human phenotypes as well to our
ontology and indexing process any one of
many tens of thousands of human genes
and any way that any of those terms the
diseases phenotypes or genes can be
described we understand which references
talk about which of those entities and
then even more fully we understand in
those genes in papers that mention genes
we understand when a variant is
described of varying in any one of those
transcripts from any one of those genes
in any position of any type non-coding
in Dells or snews as well as whether the
authors have used a conventionally
accepted nomenclature or have deviated
from that accepted nomenclature this is
in essence what genomic on has been
working toward for the better part of
the last five years is perfecting this
art of recognizing these pieces
of the puzzle these sources of evidence
for interpreting the variants and then
presenting that data in a way that
really resonates with existing workflows
for brilliant scientists so without
showing you everything in the the
software this is a reflection of some of
the data component features that we have
in the mastermind software on the Left
you'll notice a comprehensive variant
landscape this happens to be for the
fibrin one gene and you can see along
the x-axis of that diagram is the linear
axis of the protein from the first
position to that the end terminus of
that protein and then on the y-axis is a
reflection of how many times each of
those variants or individual bars has
been cited in the literature and then in
that diagram there you can see if the
functional domains that comprise that
protein so I chose febrile and one which
is a loss of tokenism because it really
underscores how exhaustive the search
the the automated search in mastermind
is and how comprehensive the data is for
each gene so this is true not just a
fibrin one and certainly not just true
of constitutional disease but truly of
the knee tens of thousands of genes in
any disease context from any one of
those references in any one of the
articles ever published and then over on
the right is a reflection of as I
suggested what we're doing to events
that data so that the variant scientists
needn't take the master software at its
word but rather can take a deep dive in
and understand fully what the author's
intended to say about that variant even
more fully we've given them the power to
enhance the specificity of their search
results where the previous slide
indicated that it's maximally sensitive
to turn your attention as a user to
specificity mode we've made it possible
for users to investigate that evidence
by prioritizing
list of articles that mention their
variant using keywords that buys the
data along ACMG guidelines so the
example that I'm showcasing here is for
a search that's looking for functionally
significant references to identify the
ps3 or B s3 the strong evidence of
pathogenicity based on functional
studies or otherwise strong Evis of a
benign variant based on those functional
assays and here's a reflection of some
of those keywords that we're using to
drive the recognition of a which of the
Articles that have cited your variant
are the most likely to convey that
functional significance and then
presents to you in the form of those
sentence
snippets from each of those references
and so that's a very high-level view in
the context of what we're talking about
today about the mastermind software and
its use in variant interpretation so the
next thing that I wanted to do here is
walk through a couple of cases that are
illustrative of the benefit of using
mastermind again for maximizing
sensitivity and specificity as well as
for very quickly showcasing the
requisite evidence from these references
that are meaningful for your workflow
automation so the first example acht
about on at least a couple of other
occasions is the URIs gene it is a
missense variant in the 73rd residue
which is assisting in the reference
situation but has changed into an
arginine and so missense variants can be
particularly challenging they're the
most numerous of all the different types
of variants for obvious reasons but
you're not able to jump to a higher tier
of likely pathogenicity as you might be
in certain circumstances for
loss-of-function variants such as
frameshift or nonsense
so missense variants can sometimes be
poly fizz um's can sometimes be
functionally inert and passenger
mutations or other
time's critically they can really damage
the functionality the protein in leads a
disease so there are somewhat enigmatic
in that way this example is a reflection
of one of those potential enigmas that
is only solvable by going out to the
literature so this variant has a low
frequency in these population databases
as I'm showing there unload the left and
further it's predicted to be damaging
providing some small supporting evidence
of pathogenicity that's the pp3 or
pathogenic supporting evidence in the
third category but those pieces of
evidence those lines of sight into the
evidence triad are not sufficient to
label this variant what's required are
two additional strong lines of evidence
or otherwise one strong line of evidence
we moderate lines of evidence and the
only recourse having exhausted the other
two arms of the Triad is to go out to
the literature and so effectively that's
what we've done in this example coming
from one of our users
we went out to PubMed in Google Scholar
or rather took their information and an
included e here and also compared those
results with mastermind and so
conventional search results here on the
left for using PubMed which basically
has insight into the titles and
abstracts of the references as well as a
little bit more penetrating insight into
Google's allure has the full complement
of full text on many of these references
the results here show that PubMed is a
shallow reflection of the data content
showing only seven of the results
compared to the hundred and nineteen
that Google Scholar results had returned
after her user has understood all of the
different ways that the gene and the
variant can be configured which is
effortful in and of itself but you'll
notice if you look closely or if you've
ever used Google Scholar those results
are very unorganized they're they're not
thoroughly annotated
Peretz there's a number of very highly
off-target results either falsely
recognizing the gene in adequately
recognizing the variant having results
with a mismatch between the the gene and
the variant or otherwise not actually
including both of the terms that you've
searched for but in Google's attempt to
produce as many results as they can
there are results that when you
investigate you can't see why those
results were returned and so just
because there's more information there
does not mean that that's a better
solution if you're trying to maximize
the sensitivity of your search certainly
that would be better but if you're
trying to enhance the automation and
efficiency of your workflow in many
circumstances the disorganized
presentation and the the cluttering of
the results with false positives can
pose a significant challenge and so
cause those two results with the results
in the mastermind search and in this
particular example we've done a pretty
deep investigation of these returned
results in all three circumstances and
in this case mastermind returned 85
results and critically there were no
duplicates reflected in those 85 results
the positive sorry have no false
positive results that were returned in
mastermind and and I think critically
importantly the results were prioritized
by clinical relevance and all of the
evidence necessary to very quickly make
a determination about which reference is
the most meaningful and to validate for
Phi how that evidence from those
references figures into the ACMG
criteria that's what mastermind does and
we make that very easy for users to the
point where a user can perform this
search on a single variant and complete
that investigation in five to fifteen
minutes which is in contract three
minutes to three hours that is otherwise
required to first identify references go
out to those references pull out that
evidence and then investigate that
evidence mastermind does all of that
legwork
front so the user can instead focus on
the cerebral effort required to
interpret the variant it's just to
underscore the benefit of mastermind
this is one of the top results I believe
the top result in mastermind for this
particular variant and immediately it's
clear based on a number of the cues that
are provided in the software the context
clues from the full text that indicate
that this is a functional four and that
the authors have ascribed a functional
significance to this variant in an in
vivo mouse model of the disease that's
associated with this gene porphyria and
so this was a result that if you saw
this variant in your clinical workflow
that you would be able to come to with a
few short minutes compared to an
otherwise disorganized and incomplete or
non comprehensive search strategy using
PubMed or Google Scholar so on the other
side I'd like to talk about a different
case this is in a different gene the pro
protein convert A's sub to listen Kexin
type 1 or pcs k1 variant it's also a
missense variant in this case it's a
phenylalanine to lysine change this
variant is absent in those population
data sets and it it has no presence in
these in silico predicted ASIS and so
we're left bereft with any meaningful
information to take this variant out of
the realm of uncertainty into either
benign or likely pathogenic and so we
perform the same investigation using the
conventional methods of PubMed and
Google dollars and there are no results
so this underscores that example that I
gave before of if you have or no results
how can you have confidence that you
haven't done something wrong in your
search or otherwise your search tools
are inadequate and in this case they
were in fact inadequate and this is it's
to the situation that we hear from many
of our users repeatedly thanking us
and praising the sensitivity of
mastermind for finding references that
they otherwise didn't know about
sometimes for a matter of years
mastermind when the search is performed
by the sir will return a paper from the
early 2000s where the variant scientists
at a given group or unaware of that
paper having been published even at that
early date again because of the
inadequacy of their search technique so
this one result in mastermind was also a
functional study and it allowed for the
designation of ps3 or functional
functional evidence of pathogenicity and
that one paper and that one item of
evidence in the ACMG framework was
enough to take the variant out of
uncertainty in like that you see and as
I indicated that is a very typical
result that our users tell us about and
why they continue using the mastermind
software so in the last perhaps five
minutes of the conversation here I'd
like to talk about what genomics overall
mission is and particularly my ambition
as a co-founder of genomic as the
current chief science officer and that
has to do with the genomic landscape
that we're able to produce for
individual genes at a client request or
otherwise us working toward producing
genomic landscapes for say the ACMG
genes or otherwise the Sanger consensus
gene set for cancer our goal is to
thoroughly annotate all of the
literature for each of these individual
genes understanding every one of the
variants in each of those genes and
providing a of the manually curated
literature evidence that indicates those
variants are pathogenic or not and this
is a very brief overview of how we're
doing that beginning with identifying
the comprehensive and focused data
content that I talked about coming from
the mastermind database
and then using artificial intelligence
or better said computational
intelligence to annotate ranked and pre
curate with a technical platform all of
those variants from all of those
literature sources before a final and
expedited manual review and I'll walk
you very quickly through each of those
steps here but that's the O or Artemis s
the first step as I alluded to we've
already done and continue to do so on a
weekly basis is updating the data
content in the mastermind database for
any disease and any gene and every
possible variant and thoroughly
annotating those those lines of evidence
with clinical and functionally
significant additions the next thing as
I said is is organizing that data which
happens to facto in the mastermind
indexing process we know where all of
these variants live in the medical
literature and what diseases they can
sort with and that's a reflection in the
master mind software of some of that
date result variant we also understand
in what contexts in in a given disease
circumstance those variants are
described does it segregate with
patients is there functionally
significant experiments that have been
performed that indicate this variant is
a bad actor a patient with the variant
is is diagnoseable with that disease as
a result and so I alluded to the ACMG
amp criteria we have a whole battery of
additional key terms such as prognostic
significance or therapeutic significance
as well as diagnostic utility these
results are ranked and prioritized using
a proprietary algorithm that takes into
account all of this information using
some bespoke data processing algorithms
that we've devised as well as some
industry standards in data science and
natural language processing
and then critically we present that
information to our team of manual
curators masters level and above data
reviewers because we know what we're
looking for and we can pattern our
technology to present those results in a
way that's sufficient for us to very
quickly adjudicate the meaningfulness of
each of those results similar to what I
showed you in the mastermind interface
with the the difference that we're able
to do this now in batch mode for many
hundreds and thousands of variants in
any given project we're able to
thoroughly annotate those results very
exhaustively and accurately according to
ACMG guidelines and then lastly those
results are delivered through the
mastermind reporter which are seeing a
reflection of here where every variant
in any one of the genes of interest for
a given study is Nvidia and the results
from the manual curation and from the
database organization are presented to
the user and those results are
continuously updated so every week we
understand what new information is
presented and every quarter those
results are updated and presented to the
user so that the database is as
comprehensive as it could possibly be
and again this is available through
project work that we're doing and in our
own internal curation efforts with a
view toward eventually subsuming the
entire human genome so that last slide
before I say that mastermind is
available to users through the basic
Edition for research purposes and with
the sign up to the mastermind basic
Edition at the link that I'm providing
there below with the code lab roots 2019
you'll get as to the mastermind
professional Edition for two weeks
mastermind professional being intended
for clinical practice in the way that I
had talked about earlier and allowing
you to see all of those streamlined Kate
abilities for enhancing the accuracy and
efficiency of your variant
interpretation workflow so that
concludes my presentation I'll reiterate
that I'm available to any of the viewers
for questions that I'll address by email
after the live event or otherwise if
you'd like to reach out and talk about
any of the the features of mastermind
the data curation projects that we're
working toward or any other
forward-looking aspect of genomics and
precision medicine I'd be happy to take
those emails so with that I'll adjourn
and thank you again for your attention